I'm going to argue, that the best answer to this is no. This code is already
fairly complex. It's got two loops in it, lots of statement and it doesn't
handle lots of cases. So let's think about the cases that it doesn't handle. It
doesn't handle the case where the, initial days are in the same month. And it
doesn't handle that, because we're adding all the days in month one, to the days
and if day two was also in month one, we're going to add that we're going to get
the wrong answer. We could handle this. Maybe we subtract the difference between
the days. We have a special case for that. Maybe we need to do something
different with this loop to account for when the months are the same. But that's
painful. We're going to need a new special case. Adding one special case is
okay. There are other cases it doesn't handle. It doesn't handle the case where
month 2 is before month 1. And this could happen if the years are different, it
would still be the case that the second date is after the first date even though
the second month is before the first month. And this won't handle that
correctly. The other thing it doesn't handle quite correctly is counting days in
leap years. This loop where we add the days in year one we have to be careful
depending on whether February is included, based on what month we're in. Whether
we should pay attention to the days in year 1 or the days in year 2. There's a
lot of things it doesn't handle. We could definitely fix this code to
handle.those. And, if you answered the second answer, I'd encourage you to try
and do that. To try and turn this into a correct working program. And you should
be able to do that, but our goal as programmers should be to try and find a
simple solution first. Something this complicated is very difficult to get
correct. Once you start handling lot's of special cases, and I've seen lots of
discussions on the forum of people who try to handle all these special cases.
It's really hard to get them all right and it makes the code very complicated.
So let's start by thinking of a simpler way. Often the way humans solve a
problem is not the simplest way, because humans are lazy. We want to find
shortcuts, instead of doing things in a real, simple, mechanical way. On the
other hand, computers are not lazy. Doing things in a simple, mechanical way is
great for computers. It makes the program easier to write, makes it more likely
to be correct.